very fond of what's happening here would
you write this carlos bustamante young
ET que no you were good to go would you
go back to using a typewriter I love
jparty you do I have a weird affinity
for them I don't know there's something
tactile and satisfying about it I mean I
wouldn't want to write a full script on
one that seems daunting yeah but there
is something really I don't know I love
them yeah I have a couple old buttons
that I really love I'm how familiar were
you with Lea's real story before you
know about it at all
I didn't I felt kind of disappointed in
myself that I didn't write know her
story and I was in New York during those
years like early 90s is when I first
moved to New York and you know sometimes
I keep thinking like did I pass her did
she tell me to stop talking like where
what you know it's like I do wonder
about that like did I do they pass her
and not even notice that's an
interesting thought because what it
seems from the film like that's
basically how she lived life right yeah
I mean there was a quality she was
somehow invisible to people and I think
she kept herself that way as a kind of
defense mechanism I don't think anybody
wants to be isolated I think it's you
know kind of I'll keep to myself so no
one hurts me is what I always had in my
head for her so kind of her you know I
always thought if she was like an
armadillo just kind of putting up this
like defensive shell but yeah I didn't
and then once I read the script I
couldn't figure out why I hadn't known
and I'm gonna cut to the FBI part and I
was like oh my god yeah like she's
fascinating her story's fascinating it's
a wild story and yeah for a story being
about like writing justice forging his
little notes
it's raizy and now are your kids your
kids have a fortress teacher for
anything have they ever gone I don't
think so I don't think they're there so
a little too young for that
I did I did that with my mom signature
we did yeah I skipped school don't do
this if anyone's watching but I did that
once and like signed my mom's name and
it was like I'd skip school for a day
see I did that with my with my dad's
signature to get away with that and I
did and that's a thing when I was
thinking about this when I was watching
the movie how easy it was for her to get
away with you want you so you had that
feeling when your kids like I could do
time yeah well especially she was so
good at it she was also right I mean she
was selling like I passed it to a nun in
high school who like would endure my
mom's writing from anybody I don't know
how good I was at I just did it because
I wish shifty at the time but you know
looking at her letters and the things
she wrote if she wasn't such an
incredible writer I mean she was writing
in all of these different voices and
doing it as well as they did or better
and that's a pretty remarkable thing to
say that you can you know that that's
the caliber of your writing I mean
that's amazing
you had said not too long ago something
to the effect of like women are always
always has to be portrayed as kind of
look perfect and now we're seeing like
you're doing this character who was so
layered and we're seeing a lot of female
characters now that are very layered and
three-dimensional and get to be human
human exactly you do think that that is
finally shifting now I certainly hope so
I mean it's what I always look for it's
me for me if it's comedy or drama or
whatever it is there's no difference I
go for a story in the character and the
character has to be three-dimensional
and it's the flaws even our dearest
friends it's like I don't know anyone
perfect I'm not friends with any I don't
know anyone perfect it's everyone's
weird ticks and peccadilloes and
eccentricities that either make us not
like them or love them or both yeah and
so when you put those into a character
and you have these things to play and
manipulate and even hide yeah that's
what I think you really get you know a
really great story yeah I love that well
I enjoy the movie so much thank you
because thank you so much thank you so
much